Guten Tag, ich bin Dr. Matt, ich bin zuständiger als für Sie, ich möchte heute mit Ihnen über Ihre Beschwerde sprechen.
Aber so als brauche ich ein paar persönlichen Daten, dann sprechen wir genau über Ihre Beschwerde.
Wie lautet Ihr Name?
Wolf.
Wolf?
Schmet.
Schmet, mein Geschenk.
Können Sie Ihr Nachname buchstabieren?
Schmet mit S-C-H-M-I-D-T.
D-T, okay. Und Vorname Wolf, ja?
Genau.
Herr Schimit, ja?
Ja, genau.
Wie alt sind Sie?
40 Jahre alt.
40 Jahre alt, wann sind Sie?
2.
3.
1982.
83 Jahre alt, ja?
Okay.
Wie groß sind Sie, Herr Schimit?
1.72.
2.70?
2.70.
Und wie viel liegen Sie?
Zuletzt war ich 75 kg.
75 kg, genau, schwer, ja?
Genau.
Sind Sie gegen einen Komiknausing geimpft?
Ja.
Das ist gut. Was kann ich für die Tonhörchen mit?
Ich fühle mich in der letzten Zeit stark.
Schlaf, müde.
Mir geht es ab und zu auch schlecht.
Seit wann leiden Sie müde?
Seit ungefähr 3-4 Wochen.
Starker war.
Aber jetzt seit 3-4 Wochen ist es jetzt vermehrt.
Okay.
Haben Sie noch eine Bescheidung?
Eigentlich nicht.
Ich habe auch Treiber Sport an.
Ich war auch sehr kein gesund.
Ich habe nie gehabt, nichts gehabt.
Haben Sie Fieber, Schütterfluss oder Schwarzausblücher?
Aktuell habe ich keine.
Bekommen Sie Schwerluft?
Nein, auch nicht.
Okay, haben Sie in letzter Zeit ab oder so genommen?
Was haben Sie abgenommen?
3-4 Kilo.
Welche Zeitung?
Seit ungefähr 3-4 Wochen.
Leiden Sie unter innerer Unruhe, Nervosität oder Trammer?
Nein, diese Nervosität kommt auch seit ich diese Probleme habe.
Ich habe mich nicht verstanden.
Ich habe mich nicht verstanden, ich habe auch diese Probleme.
Ich habe nicht gehabt, aber das macht mich schon Gedanken.
Dass es mir in den letzten Tagen oder Wochen schlecht geht.
Das macht mich schon Angst.
Okay, haben Sie irgendwelche Schmerzen?
Nein, ich habe keine Schmerzen.
Ich habe es nicht gemerkt.
Sie sind vielleicht noch aufgewachsen mit der Vergrößerung.
In der Aktion, die man so leicht verursacht.
Ich habe es nicht getastet oder geschaut, aber ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich habe es nicht untersucht selbst.
Okay, alles klar.
Haben Sie Bemerk, dass Sie mehr durch das Ausgefahren nicht?
Noch mal bitte.
Haben Sie Bemerk, dass Sie mehr durch das Ausgefahren nicht haben?
Mehr durch, meinst du?
Ja, ja, ja.
Nein, ganz normal.
Müssten Sie mehrmals auf die Toilette gehen in der Nacht?
Auch nicht.
Okay, haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden?
Ich überlege mich jetzt, ja, so ein bisschen Verstopfung, aber ansonsten auch nicht.
Das ist halt normal, weil ich wenig trinke.
Nicht weniger normal, vielleicht das wenig, weil es nicht genau, ich kann es nicht genau beurteilen.
Aber ich ernehne mich auch nicht ganz regelmäßig, ja, durch die ganze Problem, was ich jetzt habe.
Alles klar.
Sind Ihnen vielleicht Haurauswahl oder Treppen, Torpazgefühl aufgefallen?
Sie sehen, dass ich Haurauswahl habe, ein bisschen, aber das kommt nicht von dem aktuellen Problem, das hatte ich immer gehabt.
Okay, wie viel Treppen können Sie schmerzfrei laufen?
Beschwerenfrei, Treppen auch gehen, ja, das sage ich ja, nehme ich an.
Ich habe ein Luftproblem, da kann ich ganz bis drunter, vierter Stock auch gehen, aber ich habe kein Problem damit.
Okay, müssen Sie mehrmals beim Schlafen beinüben?
Nee, muss ich auch nicht.
Okay, Sie haben noch Müdigkeit, ja?
Ja, ich habe Müdigkeit, genau.
Außer dieser Beschwerden haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden?
Nee, leicht ab und zu Bauchschmelzen, aber es ist auch nicht so ausgeprägt, ja.
Ich glaube, hier hätte ich es ab und zu Bauchschmelzen, das ist nicht was Neues.
Haben Sie verstopft oder laufen der Nase bemerkt?
Nee, habe ich auch nicht.
Ist Ihnen vielleicht aufgefallen, dass Sie Bläs aussehen?
Nee, ich sehe mich jeden Tag, aber mir ist nicht so was aufgefallen.
Hab ich Sie noch einen der Beschwerden?
Nee, habe ich gar keinen anderen Beschwerden, das reicht erst mal, was ich jetzt habe.
Haben Sie Energie, etwas zu machen?
Ja, in der letzten Zeit, ich hatte es, aber in der letzten Zeit, es fehlt ganz schwer,
dass ich noch etwas zu üben oder zu machen,
versuche auch von meiner Freunde umkreuzt, einfach es fein zu halten,
weil die bieten vieles an, was ich nicht mitmachen kann, ja.
Ich habe kein Wasser drauf.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Schutul oder Wasserlassen?
Noch mal bitte.
Wie ist die Schutul oder Wasserlassen?
Hab ich vorhin gesagt, ich habe etwas Verstoffen, aber Wasserlassen ist normal.
Schlafen Sie gut?
Ja, das tue ich schon, keine Zeit.
Okay, haben Sie in letzter Zeit, in der letzten Zeit, Abmodus genommen?
Ja, Sie haben schon gesagt, 3 Kilogramm abgenommen.
Okay, nun würde ich über Ihre Vorerkrankungen sprechen,
aber davor, möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Nee.
Leiden Sie an die Regentwärtschaft vor Erkrankungen?
Ja, habe ich auch keine. Ich bin 40 Jahre alt, was ich vorgegangen habe.
Nehmen Sie die gentrische Medikamente ein?
Auch nicht.
Abmodus für Spassmetallia, aber auch wieder nicht, dass ich dauerhaft einnehmen muss.
Okay.
Sind Sie schon mal oprät worden?
Nein, auch nicht.
Nein, okay.
Wurden Ihnen schon mal stationär aufgenommen?
Auch nicht.
Sind bei Ihnen Allergien bekannt?
Vertragen Sie Milchprodukte getragen?
Ob es Autorgemöse?
Ich habe keine Lebensmetallologie oder Unverträglichkeit, ich kann alles ganz normal essen.
Okay, das ist gut.
Rauchen Sie?
Ja.
Was rauchen Sie und wie oft rauchen Sie?
Ganz normal, das ist normal.
10 bis 15 Stück pro Tag, nicht mehr.
Seid wann rauchen Sie?
Seit 10 Jahren.
Seit 10 Jahren?
Haben Sie da Folgen erhofft?
Auch nicht, nein.
1-2 Bier pro Tag.
Ab dem Wochenende vielleicht ein Glas Wein oder ein, 2 Glas Wein.
Aber seit 4 Wochen habe ich auch nicht mehr geschafft, seit ich schlapp und müde bin.
Ich habe keine Lust mehr.
Nehmen Sie die Kette, welche Du hast?
Okay Herr Schmidt, wie ist Ihr Familienstand?
Ich habe keine Lust mehr.
Was sind Sie von Beruf?
Ich bin Taxi-Fahrer.
Sind Sie oft Stress ausgesetzt?
Ja, das ist so.
Wenn man mit den Menschen immer Kontakt hat, dann kriegt man Stress.
Nehmen Sie alle?
Ja, ich lebe alleine.
Jetzt kommen wir zur Familiengeschichte.
Gibt es in der Familie eine
ganz symptomfreie Mutter?
Sie ist auch kein gesundes.
Sie hat nie etwas gehabt.
Sie geht nie so aus.
Ich habe richtig verstanden, dass Ihre Mutter gesund ist.
Ja, genau.
Herr Schmidt, das war meine Frage.
Haben Sie Fragen oder möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Nein, ich habe keine.
Was fragen wir denn?
Haben wir alles gefragt oder sollen wir etwas fragen?
Haben Sie das Blut im Kultur gesehen?
Nein, gute Frage.
Die Farbe ist ein bisschen komisch, aber ich habe keine Blut gesehen.
Haben Sie eine Brut mit Blut?
Nein, ich habe es manchmal schlecht, aber es ist nicht so.
Haben Sie eine Hautveränderung bemerkt?
Nein, ich habe auch keine.
Was noch?
Haben Sie eine Bauchschmerzen bemerkt?
Ja, aber es war nicht so ausgeprägt.
Wie sieht Ihr Sturrgang aus?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Es sieht ein bisschen dunkel aus, aber es war manchmal hell,
manchmal dunkel, so ein Wechselhaft.
Aber als Sie gesagt haben, ich habe auch nicht so stark,
sondern durch die Verstoffung, ich habe keine regelmäßige Sturrgang.
Riecht es, da ist die Tule auch?
Nein, manchmal ja, manchmal nicht.
Manchmal haben Sie Druckfall?
Guter Frage.
Manchmal ist dunkel, nicht durchfallbar, aber es ist dunkel.
Schweißausbruch wurde nicht gefragt?
Ja, schon gefragt.
Ich habe die erste Frage.
Aber Sie haben viel überrascht, aber ich habe keine.
Sie haben viel überrascht.
Ich habe 3 Sturrgangs.
Sie sind so einfach, dann habe ich nicht gehört.
Ich habe noch das Schweißausbruch.
Ich weiß.
Stopping.
Können wir erst einmal sagen,
wir haben einen neuen Patient,
nämlich Wolf Schimmit.
Ich würde über ihn berichten, darf ich?
Ja, gerne.
Herr Schimmit ist 40 Jahre alt, 1,72 m,
75 kg schwer.
Ich habe einen neuen Patient,
aber ich habe eine andere Patient,
wir haben hier einen neuen Patient,
wir haben eine neue Patient,
wir haben keine.
Ich habe einen neuen Patient,
Melana und Gewichtsverlust von 3 bis 4 kg in einer Halbfond 3 bis 4 Wochen.
Die vegetative Anemneser, ergaubste Passion und nächtliche Hyperhydrose,
die vor ergaubsten Erkrankungen sind unbekannt.
Herr Schimit nimmt keine Medikamente und er ist bis her noch nie operiert worden.
Allergin und Unvertretlichkeiten sind bei ihm unbekannt.
Er ist seit 10 Jahren 10 bis 15 Sekunden Technik geraucht.
Er trinkt geregend nicht ein Flasche, Bier oder ein bis 2 Klasse Wein.
Der Ölkonsum wurde verleicht.
Er ist ledig und er wohnt allein.
Er ist der Erkrankungsverlust, er ist der Erkrankungsverlust,
er leidet unter Fischdresse.
Der Vater des Patienten ist wegen einem Magenkarsinum operiert worden.
Er hat momentan keine Beschwerden.
Die Mutter des Patienten ist gesund.
Die Anemnestation ist unbekannt.
Er ist ein
Anemnestationangaben in Deutschland, Amerika und Deutschland.
Er ist auch ein Anemnestation in Deutschland.
Sie sind schnell und sehr gut.
Was haben Sie in den Passenden?
Ich überprüfe die Teilkometer,
dann würde ich die Körperleuchter unterwerfen.
Danach nehme ich Blutab,
außer im Blutbild beurteile ich eines Blutbildes,
der Nierenwörter.
Ich mache die Nierenwörter.
Das ist die Nierenwörter, die ich mache.
Das ist weiter wichtig. Nein, das ist bei Punklin, aber kann man beides machen.
Außer dann würde ich Schutton Probe.
Wie machen Sie das?
Schutton Probe oder?
Machen Sie auch digitale Rectale und Person.
Ja.
Was würden Sie als erstes machen, bevor Sie die Stunden untersuchen?
Bei der Körperlik-Untersuchung würde ich die digitale Rectale untersuchen.
Sie waren noch durch?
Ja.
Außer dann haben wir auch Kultes, so überprüft werden.
Hat der Kollegen geschrieben den Chat?
Ich war auf der Strecke, ja.
Ja, richtig, ja.
Die ganze Sache, was Sie mir erzählt haben, können Sie in der Praxis machen.
Genau, richtig.
Wenn Sie im Klinik sind, was machen Sie denn?
In der Klinik?
Wollen Sie Effektest machen oder würden Sie Stub-Test veranlassen?
Je nach Klinik.
Wir werden überprüfen.
Haben Sie auch Kultest oder Stundprobe?
Ja, das ist in Deutschland ein bisschen ungewöhnlich.
Man macht das im Klinik am meisten nicht.
Man sagt, wenn man Verdacht auf der Angriffs hat,
gehen wir mit einem Kuliskopier rein und dann gucken wir das an.
Kuliskopier ist der erforderlich, ja?
Ja, da sage ich, warum soll ich den Kulte oder Effektest machen,
wenn ich den DOSA-Test direkt sehen kann.
Das ist die erste Untersuchung.
Aber Sie haben ein Problem, weil in der Praxis es so laufen muss,
bevor Sie zum einen DOSA-Test schicken.
Das ist richtig.
Was machen Sie im Körperuntersuchung noch? Was achten Sie?
Ich würde als Bauchuntersuchung durchführen.
Beim Inspektion sehe ich irgendwelche Narben oder Hautveränderungen,
Hautfarbeveränderungen oder irgendwelche Bulaufileke.
Beim Palfassion überprüfe ich ganze Bauchteile.
Besonders Abwehrspannung oder Loslasten überprüfen.
Aber beim Kolonkurs noch erwarte ich eine Masse.
Beim Palfassion erwarte ich ein Masse im Bau.
Das ist richtig, genau.
Die Tiefpalfassion, ja.
Die Hautveränderungen sieht man selten.
Pflecken sieht man selten.
Das ist eher ungewöhnlich.
Wenn man eine Grinnungsverkaufstörung hat,
kann das auch vorkommen.
Aber das ist ungewöhnlich.
Trotzdem kann man das achten.
Was achten Sie noch?
Beim Auskitation.
Noch eine Körperuntersuchung.
Ja, eine Körperuntersuchung.
Und gar eine Megaläe, eine Leberverkaufstörung.
Ja, ja, genau.
Mehlverkaufstörung, ja.
Leberverkaufstörung, 7. Megaläe.
Lymphfrohtenverkaufstörung.
Ja, das wird man auch machen.
Dann weiter.
Was machen Sie weiter?
Ich habe gesagt, Sie kriegen eine kleine Routine.
Ich finde das groß am Ende.
Ich werde das groß machen.
Sie haben gesagt, nie ein weiterer Leber,
ein weiterer großer Blutwelt.
Das haben Sie erwähnt.
Genau, warum nehmen Sie die Rinnungs?
Die Rinnungs...
Eigentlich würde ich gerne nichts weiter überprüfen,
weil da passiert ein Kohlospoffie.
Das ist ein Kohlospoffie.
Ja, richtig.
Für eine mögliche OP, ja.
Sofort wird man nicht operieren,
außer wenn man eine Stenose hat, hat er recht.
Wenn jemand mit starker Bauchschmerzen kommt,
verdacht er auf Idios, dann ist die Indikation
für eine auch wenn es palliativ ist oder kurativ ist,
für eine OP, genau, richtig.
In dieser Sitzung geht es um eine Vorbereitung
für eine Untersuchung für die nächste Maßnahme.
Das ist der Darmspegnen.
Oder Magenspegnen, um Beides wirklich zu machen.
Nicht nur Magenspegnen, sondern auch Magen.
Sie haben das gemacht.
Sie haben gesehen, bei ungefähr einem Transverskolon,
eine große Perde,
eine große Maß,
und sie haben es biopsiert.
Und kam raus, dass eine Tumor ist.
Das machen sie weiter.
Ja, beide Kohlospie, oder?
Ja, sie haben es biopsiert, kam Tumor raus.
Es gesichert durch die Patologen.
Ja,
je nach biopsiergebnis
planen wir eine Operation.
Was machen Sie?
Normalerweise ist die Stologie nicht so schnell,
aber sie haben uns koloskopiert gesehen.
Und dass ein Tumor da sitzt.
Die Stologie weiß noch nicht genau.
Wir sollen überprüfen, ob der Patient
hat eine andere Methastasen oder wie groß
diese, wie groß.
Was machen Sie denn?
Ja, ich so CT veranlasst.
Sehr gut.
Was ist CT oder MAT?
Eigentlich CT würde ich sagen.
Warum nicht MAT?
Beim MAT überprüfen
wir eine Knochen
oder Nervenstem,
eine weiche, weiche
Ja, aber mit dem CT können wir auch
durch Blutung
geben.
Wenn Sie eine Bauchfeldmetastase haben,
sehen Sie es im CT oder MAT?
Kontrast mit CT können wir diese
Metastasen gut erkennen.
Mit MAT oder CT?
MAT.
Haben wir Radioloren?
Es wirkt nicht rein.
Sind Sie Radioloren?
Ich habe aus Nr.
aus in der Druckerarbeit.
Es ist ein Standard, bei jungen Patient
macht man immer MAT.
Weil die Darstellung von den
Stilungen, die wir haben,
ist besser mit MAT als mit CT.
Position Emission Tomography?
Was ist denn Konsequenz?
Position PET.
Position Emission Tomography.
Das macht man nicht standard,
solange man CT oder MAT macht.
MAT macht natürlich CT oder MAT
hat keine andere Fragestellung.
Wenn das unklar ist,
dann kann man machen.
Bei Darmclips ist es nicht standard.
Nur bei Nr.
Rintumor oder Lungenpatienten,
die eine korrektive Sitzung hat,
das braucht man mit der Turbo-Bord.
Das geht nicht so einfach in Deutschland.
Das geht nicht in der Türkei.
Wenn Sie es machen,
brauchen Sie wieder eine CT, das zu vergleichen.
Das stimmt, was die CT sagt.
Die CT aufnimmt und zeigt,
das ist nicht das Metastasis.
Das könnte auch eine Entzündung sein.
Da müssen Sie wieder mit normales Bild gehen
und vergleichen, ob das doch Entzündung ist.
Es ist ein Standardverfahren.
Wenn man eine CT macht,
dann macht man eine MAT besser als CT.
CT ist auch nicht verkehrt, kann man machen.
Aber wenn man eine andere Frage hat,
ob man Lapsoskopieren muss,
dann setzt nicht in Lapsoskopie.
Das ist etwas anderes.
Aber vor der OP ist besser,
eine MAT zu machen.
Das ist auch ein Standardverfahren.
Die Tumor ist genau, wie die sich darstellt.
Eine MAT sieht man besser als CT.
Ich bin nicht katholok, es ist nur Erfahrungssache,
was wir benutzen in der Altenfunkologie.
Die Radilone sagen auch,
MAT ist besser als CT.
Bei Bauch, aber Torax, keine MAT.
Erma CT, Standardpunkten gibt es keine Diskussion.
Sie haben gesagt, MAT ist besser als CT.
Sie haben richtig gestischt.
Sie haben gesehen, dass es eine lokale Tumor ist.
Was machen Sie denn weiter?
Wir bestimmen,
wir sollen Grad und Stadium
von Karsunom bestimmen.
Das machen Sie natürlich anhand
Ihrer CT-Bildgierung.
Je nach Karsunom-Kolang,
je nach MASS,
planen wir eine Operation.
Da passiert,
braucht vielleicht eine Anusperiata.
Noch mal was braucht?
Wir sollen diese MASS entfernen.
Da braucht man eine Operation.
Wir wollen diese MASS entfernen.
Wir wollen nicht in Detail gehen.
Das ist nicht wichtig.
Das ist ein anderer Verfahren.
Das ist eine churische Sache.
Aber dass Sie das gesehen haben, lokal.
Wenn das metastasiert ist, was machen Sie denn?
Einfach zum Unkuloren überweisen.
Unkuloren, ja.
Ich soll Unkulärgeschäfte anmelden.
Das ist nichts mehr.
Das war einfach so ein Allgemeinste,
dass man die Alte kennt.
Wenn man so etwas sieht, wie man damit umgeht,
wenn Sie ein bisschen ökologisch was haben,
ökologisch ist da einfach das Weg.
Einfach Konziliarischvorstellung in denjenigen Abteilungen,
die sich damit kennt.
Dann sind Sie raus aus dem Spiel.
Dann ist das so.
Wir haben Fehler gesucht.
Sie haben es toll gemacht.
Sie machen es toll in der Prüfung.
Ich möchte eine Hinsäpfige anstellen.
Ich möchte meine Kollegen anstellen.
Ich würde am Anfang,
wenn Oberarzt eine Prozedüre gestellt hat,
ich würde gerne erst mal
eine hierrige und
ökologische Konsul
von Erfohren.
Und dann müssen wir ...
Wenn man so etwas hat,
das muss in der Tumorboard vorgestellt werden.
Wenn Sie eine Patient haben
mit so einer Tumorart, das muss egal sein.
Das ist eine Art,
die man in der Tumorboard hat.
Das muss egal, welcher Stadium spielt,
keine Rolle.
Die Tumorboard ist die Sitzung von Herd.
Sie sind auch der Unkuloren.
Dann sind Sie garantiert versichert.
Dann ist die richtige Verfahren
oder die richtige Maßnahme dort entschieden.
Dann wird gemacht.
Sie können nicht so etwas alleine entscheiden.
Das ist auch nicht so.
Als Unkulore darf ich auch nicht.
Aber muss ich sicher sein,
dass ich das so ist.
Manchmal behandeln die Patient schon im Vorfeld.
Dann stelle ich die Tumorboard formal.
Ich weiß, dass die Tumorboard nicht anders rauskommt.
Aber so ein Komplex,
falls das nicht komplex ist,
dass die Tumorboard normal ist,
ist das Versicherung der Verfahren nicht,
dass es später jemanden sich beschwert.
Aber wenn das was unklar ist, immer Tumorboard.
Wie heißt auf Deutsch Herd?
Tumorboard.
Das ist ein Wort von Tumors.
Danke schön.
Dann muss man nehmen, Tumorboard vorstellen.